hey guys i'm ryan right and I am Jerry
Jerry and all you're going to do the 1up
box today yeah Irish accents are brought
to you by the fact that this is green
this is grain they're after me lucky
sure my Irish accent isn't actually that
good I gotta get better instead I could
do it i am from Ireland yeah but it's
very hard to do it over sex it like just
to do it normal like with that dunno
well the like sing-songy leprechaun the
shade it's like if you want to like a
Colin Farrell or you know if you want to
do like an actual just like regular
Irish accent it's much harder this is
realism they're fans of the channel so i
don't actually [ __ ] with these kids but
man making not knowing me sometimes with
the noise they make yes you guys are
watching this video how to adventure
just listen and don't play outside my
door anymore what up box I'm gonna see
what I get to play with and Jerry please
do the honors yes ma'am I was not
expecting me unveiling my new toys to me
maybe i'll give you one who knows i make
an incision along the seam here ok peel
back I don't know what the theme is so
look for the paper first like that is
that explains what the theme is its
pixels this time around pixels ok I
think it just means video games not the
beloved Adam Sandler ok all right let's
do this here we go I'm gonna start you
off with this here minecraft plush toy
whoo a little tiger thing or lion it's
like a little wine guy look how cool
this is my cats are gonna love this
because I not play with this enough but
I want to play with it maybe you think
this could fit up but you know what
we'll talk about that after the video I
don't know wanna know where they're no
you know exactly where that questions
going um ok the [ __ ] will it fit up
the [ __ ] it's plushie probably
yeah well coconut oil could help while
you're doing that you can you know dress
like a Chippendales dancer with this
8-bit bowtie 8-bit bowtie you were a bit
boat i specially when you do your movie
reviews is the suit jacket whoa it's
like a legit bow tie I mean kind of look
at that oh dude I look like I would love
for Veronica to like wear this around my
neck and like pull on the string like
make me her [ __ ] you know looks like a
choke chain in a way this one of you so
you just a sufferer you like a course
I'm like a power so are you like a
switch it's like I tell her what you do
to me like shoved in my mouth [ __ ]
rocket what removing on people who are
moving on okay I make a very different
unboxing videos this next one's cool I
think this next one is a build-your-own
a QB paper oh cool so sweet hey QB looks
a lot like Kirby it looks like a cross
like a Jesus Christ cross everything to
yourself I wish things were more QB well
now they are this adorable DIY cube will
provide you with minutes of fun while
you was Miss a fun you will enjoy
minutes realistic i will go by fast
while you assemble it and then you'll
have an awesome cute companion forever
oh wow it's not even gonna decompose my
cats are gonna love this too um what do
we have next here Oh up I guess this is
like a primo thing it's on the bottom
half of the page uh you get this pack of
8-bit stickers oh cool yeah whoa are
those superheroes stick them lick them
flick and pick them oh dude you got
Batman Joker Robin Superman flash
ironmen oh my god it's like pics the
Ninja Turtles yeah those are freaking
cool mario and Luigi's ant-man there's
no oh can I fit in Jake yeah you could
have Finn and Jake look how cool this
[ __ ] is so
look how cool they [ __ ] as much as
superheroes pixels okay here you go you
what did you want a week and it we can
do do that later no I want the camera to
see I'm a nice giving humans oh well
then let me see the look at that see you
see the show we can't shake in the box
up oh no oh [ __ ] I mean I love
spider-man no man you get Nick and dick
or whatever his name is there's two
spider-man all right get spider-man and
there's like this other guy who might be
venom I don't know then there's yeah
that's just a black guy Finn and Jake
it's not know hey omega man megaman
there's a power and there's Ryu there's
Harry Potter Pikachu Harry Potter right
next to Pikachu that guy ant-man Loki
fantastic four people that's great
cheese one move on okay I want these 2
i'm finn and jake and maybe a spider man
okay cool indecision is the thief of
opportunity my friends but you know
what's not the thief of opportunity this
1up box September 2015 button that's an
opportunity oh it's Deadpool yeah 1up
box dead pulpit next we have this
necklace necklace giving me [ __ ] like a
sward it's dangerous to go alone take
this creepers won't even shrugging
crappy with you plus you'll look stylish
it's a pixel sword that's pretty ba if
you know what they'll take we talking
about man this is the one necklace I own
now oh cool hey everybody got one or
well not everybody but you know it's a
part it's kind of a rite of passage oh
yeah totally home I remembered how
necklace you want to do no I got oh dude
hangs low to do this is a good show
chain you know I'm ancient cool honest
you gave me shove the sword down my
throat like chill on a [ __ ] oh that's
cool it's blue dancing you gotta make
sure it faces forward oh sweet choke in
and then last but most certainly not
least and also very bad ass is this
t-shirt with all different
character this I've been waiting for
them to send a black shirt over oh my
god cuz you know I'm like more the
darker color kind of guy when it comes
to shirts yes quetta side of which
pixelated character is your favorite our
exclusive shirt has got you covered they
got an n64 controller favorite video
game characters we got a neighbor CEO
games you are now ready for that
flawless outfit of the day got a Super
Nintendo controller dudes [ __ ] its star
[ __ ] you come to star fox star fox star
fox little space invaders gonna catch
you Sonic yeah and 64 controller hmm not
a super nintendo controller too all
right it's that time piffle chill nipple
chill it's time Oh clear the area for
this actually you look really good with
that sword on because it just Falls
right between your pecs thanks you look
like some kind of guy in like a boogie
nights style movie hella Buddha jacuzzi
with a drink like John Leguizamo from
Romeo and Juliet that's a good sure it's
a good sure on you Hales yeah which part
of town me that box we're gonna do New
thumbnail well guys um it makes my arms
look good when i flex anyway guys I'm
gonna tell you something you can yes I
remember now you can purchase on what a
box in the referral link in the
description box so go there by a 1up box
I don't get any commission from that
nope no Commission think so doing this
out of the kindness of my heart cuz you
need cool stuff to uni cool slow to it I
just trying to help you out I make zero
money just don't ask 1up box up about
that you know just don't don't tell him
I said that okay trouble in the special
instructions box of your order Ryan said
he's not making anything you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
check out reasons to Jerry and dank ass
stubs on this channel playlist hosted by
said Jerry follow us on Facebook
Instagram Twitter vine and periscope and
yeah don't forget to get a one-off box
because it
rotz 1up box rocks your [ __ ] I want you
guys to tweet that to 1up box 1up box
rocks my [ __ ] even if you have a [ __ ]
1up box rocks might [ __ ] say that